welcome back as a car Enthusiast I'm
happy to tell you that Mesquite
motormania is back this weekend at the
Casablanca Resort and Casino who are the
sponsors of this next segment and here
to tell us all about it is assistant
general manager Christian Andersen
welcome to the show thanks for me on JC
give everyone the history the back story
on mesquite Motor Mania yeah we're ready
to celebrate our 15th anniversary of
Mesquite Motor Mania and we're going to
welcome 900 cars up to Mosquito and the
Casablanca Resort this weekend so Friday
Saturday and Sunday if you're a car fan
we're it's open to all makes and models
if you're a custom a classic or even a
rat rod fan coming up to the Casablanca
you're gonna see that car this weekend
uh I've been out there before to this
show and you do have every single type
of car out there and it's a
family-friendly event as well this is
fun for the entire family absolutely you
know the best part is it's free to the
public to attend and they can come up
they can walk through all the show and
shine areas that we have at all the
properties that that are part of
Mesquite Motor Mania they also vote on
their favorite car and that goes to the
total prize for the event as well how
many different prizes are you guys
giving away this weekend well it could
be giving away over 260 prizes and
fifteen thousand dollars in cash if
someone's watching right now and they
want to bring their car down or I'm
sorry to say up to the show can they
still bring the car and get in the into
the show Absolutely you can register
your car right there at the festival
just come to the Casablanca Resort
registration will be in the showroom
stop in there get your beautiful car
registered we'd love to have you up
there this weekend with actually our
people bringing their cars down because
when I was up there I've been people
from Denver and up north that drive down
to the show that's how big it is yeah
mosquito motor made it really kicks off
the whole western region of car shows
for the year so we have folks from all
over the region that bring their cars
down the weather's great it's great
people and it's a great car show it's
huge now let's talk about uh some awards
that you guys have won uh best of last
Las Vegas three years in a row for best
destination how does it make you feel
feels fantastic you know the the support
we get from the Vegas Valley and people
that come and stay with us you know our
Hospitality our great special events
like Mesquite Motor Mania are fantastic
our great Steakhouse when you put all
those things together it's a great
vacation up at the Casablanca Resort it
is and people can make a weekend out of
it if they wanted to so there are rooms
available How do they like in rooms
rooms absolutely you can sell your rooms
available they are going fast and we got
a lot of folks coming up for Mesquite
Motor Mania so between the Casablanca
Resort and the Virgin River hotel we'll
be able to take care of you guys when
you come up for the weekend and there's
also something too when I was up there
doing it again this year there was like
Road art as well and car parts it's more
than just a car show it's a car event
yeah you know I think that's the neat
thing about our event is you get to see
these beautiful vehicles but you can see
what's under the hood as well yeah we
have burnout competitions we have a slow
drag competition we have a roaring
engine competition and we have an open
header cruise through Mesquite as well
so you get to see and vote for your
favorite car but you get to see those
cars in action and if again if you're a
car fan that's what you love Yeah well
I'll see you this weekend thank you for
coming on the show and thank you to
Casablanca Resort and Casino if we're
sponsoring this segment Mesquite Motor
Mania starts this Friday through Sunday
for more information call
877-438-2929 or visit
casablancaresorts.com